[Musique]
c'est des malades si on bat cb on va
danser
cela-dit lalalalala on va acheter des
malades ou pas d'ancêtres hall alors pas
touche ça ces marées vertes est au
boulot ou un petit moment un peu dessus
fatri parce que tels ils sont bons ils
sont pas chères d'accord c'est pas vrai
que ça recommence
honnêtement si vive rail ans avait un
petit code promo et bassam chance d'être
téléguidés emploie aujourd'hui 1
l'église en cause son bidon mondiale
webo la boulette dans la boulette
claudie qu elle voulait plus et de
l'amour pq n'en faut jusqu'en enfer
tu me laisses h que si j'en fais
toujours trop alors benoît
il est content son costume tu connais
mon costume mais c'est bien je voulais
être céline dion tu te fous ni lâcher en
espèces de peter je suis à la fois un
homme une femme on sait pas ça atteinte
à la dignité
je te déteste ça en plus j'ai regardé
céline dion très limité céline dion
c'est moi c'est moi céline bonjour
l'ambiance dégoûtée je suis dégoûtée
mais c'est toi que 80 ma carrière dans
l'oeuf cette fois j'ai compris c'est la
théorie du complot
ah non tenez vous franchement on pouvait
plus s'en prendre aux récents coups tout
le monde j'espère que vous allez bien
nous va chez very bad trip
alors je vous ai pas préciser je suis
pas en batterie mais je suis en train de
regarder le film parce que j'ai déjà des
commentaires ça va pas mais non tout va
très bien
vimont nous balance à lure de voir ça
nous fait des bonbons mathieu fecteau
causes non ça madame ennuis laddh
[Musique]
ça
recevoir un passage polynésiens et
maintenant on va partir sur une telle
et janvier qui à côté de moi je
comprends pas et il me dit c'est ta
question bonjour me changer pour
l'émission et je voulais montrer un
scoop est vraiment énorme scoop je kelly
pas vendre et voilà waouh à les ventes
est une base et un peu tu ne produis pas
du tout me produite la même chose du
tout bois à la flopée de ma seule de
toute beauté de tout pout tous deux ans
basi
[Musique]